on top of the double whammy from the US
Supreme Court today Democrats are also
licking their wounds over an unexpected
primary loss house Democratic caucus
chairman Joe Crowley of New York was
upset by a political neophyte and
self-described socialist chief national
correspondent Edie Henry looks at what
this says potentially about a divided
Democratic Party an earthquake for
Democrats as a powerful congressman
potentially in line to replace Nancy
Pelosi as party leader Joe Crowley lost
his primary to a new coming 28 year old
socialist Alexandria Ocasio Cortes a
disciple of socialist senator Bernie
Sanders who says she wants Medicare for
all so-called free tuition for college
students and wants to abolish ice which
protects the nation's borders gone is
the party of JFK here is the party of
radical socialism Pelosi was in a race
of her own today to insist
Crowley's turf in Queens New York is so
liberal it does not mean bigger trouble
nationally they made a choice in one
district so let's not get yourself
carried away except Pelosi said the
opposite in 2014 when Republican
majority leader eric cantor lost his
primary the republican party going even
further to the right the question for
Pelosi now is whether the blue wave
she's hyping for a November takeover of
the house is starting to boomerang as
Republicans get fired up by the tilt to
the left which includes Democrat Maxine
Waters calling for more protests and
verbal attacks targeting aides to
President Trump there was a time in
America's history where you could be
denied service in a restaurant based on
the color of your skin now apparently
it's the color of your voter
registration card so mr. chairman if you
want to talk about civility you start
with the President of the United States
in New York Ocasio Cortez had a much
more uplifting message about a working
mom with limited money and a young
latina taking out a party boss thrilled
Bernie Sanders we're seeing a whole lot
of young people getting involved in our
revolution organization getting involved
in grassroots campaign that energy is a
good sign
for Democrats in safe liberal seats but
it could get more complicated in
moderate House districts and read Senate
seats as a GOP base already amped up by
the retirement of Justice Anthony
Kennedy will get frequent reminders
about socialist rising it was a stunning
development the energy and the
Democratic Party is self-avowed
socialist open borders another boost for
the GOP base may come from the fact that
Crowley's owl ster makes it more likely
that Pelosi will stay on as either
speaker or Minority Leader
so she'll remain front and center and
Republican attack ads this fall Brett
Eadie thank you